كان في محاكمات
محاكمات محكمه امن الدوله العليا الشهيره
بسوريا هاي سيئه الصيت
وانا كوني كنت من اوائل المعتقلين
بدات المحاكمات كان مضيان علي اكثر من عشر
سنوات وفي نص القانون موجود انه ان لم
تحرك الدعوه العامه ضد المتهم خلال فتره
عشر سنوات تسقط بالتقادم فانا يعني استمرت
محاكمتي وقت اللي بلش المحكمه كان صار لي
11 سنه بالسجن ثمره المحكمه سنتين حتى صدر
حكم بسقوط التهمه بالتقادم وطلعت شخصيا
حتى بالمده الزمنيه
شبه الى هذا الحد بينك وبين حاله صديقك
البطل الاخر في الروايه حتى في فرق بيني
وبين
كل ما حصل لك وما حصل له هلا في تطابق
بالوقائع
الطابق الوقائع وابي بالتعذيب كذا مو بس
انا وياه يعني كل من مر بتجربه تدمر يعني
نفس الظروف نفس التعذيب نفس الاشخاص نفس
السجانين نفس مدير السجن نفس مساعد
الانضباط كله وخروج من المعتقل كيف كان
شعورك وما اول ما اردت ان تفعله بعد ذلك
انا كنت مقرر لكن عم نحكي يعني احلام
الصغيره يعني انه انا اول شغله لازم
اسويها اني اروح على الحمام حمام السوق
حمام السوق الشهيره في سوريا يعني حمام
السوق بسوريا
البلدان الثانيه نفس الشيء بيقدموا لك
خدمه هاي الخدمه الخمس نجومة يعني بمعنى
انه في مليف واحد بيليفك وفي
يعني
اسمه الحمام التركي يعني انه انا اروح
بمعنى استرخي
في جو الحمام الحار والمياه السخنه وانه
استرخي على بلاط الحمام بس يمكن لما يصير
المراد موجود ببطل مرغوب
اطلعنا
عدم تصديق ضلينا يعني حاله عدم تصديق حتى
صرنا خارج السور السجن طلعنا خمسه سوا
خمسه كنا محكومين بالتقادم يعني
واصلنا بالشارع وشفنا في حاله انبهار كمان
بس ما بيكون في سعاده حقيقيه بالبدايه
ربما يعني في حاله تعويم التعويم
بمعنى
تحدد بالضبط
وكيف قررت المغادره
مغادره الى اين مغادره سوريا نهائيا
لماذا كنا ممنوعين من السفر
بالضبط عندما سمح لك يعني لماذا قررت ان
تسافر بدي كان بدها تطلع القوقعه
وما في يعني ما في ما بتطلع القوقعه طالما
انا موجود بسوريا بس هالشي كلهن عكس بمعنى
على بمعنى او باخر على هويتك او على
انتمائك
نفس تعلقي نفسي
ولحد الان متعلق بشكل مرضي بسوريا يعني